avec un guillaume martin avocat et
membre de l'observatoire parisien des
libertés publiques bonsoir guillaume
martin merci d'être avec nous une
première réaction de votre part la
mobilisation au lierse qu'on aurait pu
dû éviter cela
le fait est que on savait au moins dans
la journée même les jours précédents
qu'il y aurait une forte mobilisation
pour ce rassemblement
que cette mobilisation serait forte
indépendamment d'ailleurs de la décision
du préfet de police d'interdire ou
d'autoriser cette manifestation
on savait qu'elles allaient avoir lieu
et effectivement je rejoins les propos
tenus par le syndicaliste policier que
vous avez fait passer à l'antenne juste
avant à savoir qu on aurait peut-être
plutôt dû choisir l'option de contrôler
cette manifestation plutôt que de
l'interdire et peut-être de laisser des
choses dégénéré voilà je crois qu'il y
avait il y avait d'autres choix
possibles mais comme c'est souvent quand
le souvent le cas en matière de maintien
de l'ordre à paris ça depuis un certain
nombre de mois voire d'années
vous dites on aurait dû éviter de voilà
je reprends mon propos de laisser les
choses dégénéré ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que d'une
certaine manière on l'espère il ya une
forme de volonté là dedans j'ai pas eu
encore de retour précis sur ce qui s'est
passé
de la manifestation d'hier ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que vraisemblablement a été
mis en place dans leur l'occasion du
rassemblement d'hier soir mêmes méthodes
qui ne fonctionne absolument pas qui
sont mises en oeuvre depuis un certain
nombre de mois dans toutes les
manifestations qui se déroulent à paris
ça a d'abord commencé avec les gilets
jaunes et puis ça s'est étendu à tous
les types de manifestations qui se sont
déroulées notamment à l'occasion des
manifestations contre la réforme la
réforme des retraites
le fait est que ce qui s'est passé hier
pour moi est la démonstration
supplémentaire un élément de plus qui
démontre qu'il ya un problème dans la
dans la politique de maintien de l'ordre
à paris et en particulier impulsée par
par le prophète police l'allemand est
calé ce problème selon vous d'un
maintien board jugé peut-être trop
musclée de votre part trop musclées
surtout on a le sentiment
systématiquement qui n recherche de
tension faire monter la tension faire
monter la pression pour que ça dégénère
et pour aussi peut-être servir un
discours politique qui permet ensuite de
dire vous on a entendu quelques minutes
auparavant sur votre antenne qui permet
de dire que les personnes qui
participent à cette manifestation sont
des quasi délinquants et qu' il ya une
réponse pénale du referme devrait être
prononcée à leur encontre
voilà je crois que il ya
une mécanique classique en réalité qui
est à l'oeuvre et qui pourrait ne pas
être du tout aux sels l'option choisie
par la préfète par le préfet de police
et par par le gouvernement on pourrait
contrôler les choses on pourrait faire
différemment pourrait tenir un discours
beaucoup plus apaisant au lieu de ça
quelques heures avant la tenue de la
manifestation alors qu'on savait qu'elle
se tiendrait on savait qu'elles seraient
massives
vous avez un appel une interdiction de
la part du préfet de cette manifestation
est évidemment que ça ne pouvait que
susciter une tension qui au final a
débouché sur quelques heures ce sur ce
qu'on a vu sur les images
alors on le rappelle un
l'un dés motifs de ce rassemblement
s'était les violences policières
présumées à la suite notamment de la
mort d' adam adama traoré
c'était il ya quatre ans a fait réagir
christophe castaner qui promet une
sanction pour chaque faute ou mot
raciste dans la police qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur à
un réel problème avec une forme de
racisme qui perdure chez certains
policiers
en réalité ministre de l'intérieur celui
ci comme les autres tiennent un discours
qui est toujours le même qui est celui
de dire qu'ils protègent leurs leurs
troupes
évidemment évidemment qu'il dénonce le
racisme
enfin au final ce qui permet d'endiguer
ce problème qui existe dans la police
française est depuis longtemps c'est
moins les discours que les actes et la
réalité c'est que il ya très peu de
sanctions prises à l'égard des policiers
aussi parce qu'il faut dire
il ya aussi très peu de dépôts de
plainte parce que il ya une comment dire
une une tendance et qui est justifiée je
crois par les faits par le fait qu'
aujourd'hui vous avez une inefficacité
de l'igpn des mécanismes de contrôle qui
qui existent mais qui sont inefficaces
pour véritablement en d'idées et
sanctionner enquêter et sanctionner
quand il le faut
lorsque des fautes sont constatées alors
en tout cas qui sauf qu'à scanner lui
justement défend ses troupes et ai dit
qu'il n'y a pas de tant de problèmes que
ça entre la police et la population 9
français sur 10 aurait une opinion
favorable de la police c'est parce que
nous dit un autre sondage un français
sur trois dit ne pas se sentir en
sécurité on va le voir s'afficher ce
sondage face à la police sondage yougov
pour le film the post aujourd'hui un
chiffre voisin qui illustre un ce
sentiment des français selon ce sondage
après ses récentes affaires qui dit vrai
qui dit faux selon vous à guillaume
martin alors moi je ne suis pas je suis
pas membre d'un institut sondages je
sais pas qui de ces deux passages
devraient difool m entre la papauté et
moi j'ai une éthique et ce sentiment là
et il existe et il est fondé il est
fondé sur le fait que ceux qui veulent
aller en manifestation aujourd'hui à
paris en particulier mais un peu partout
en france doivent être assez courageux
pour se décider à le faire parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils pourront être gazés
pouvoir matraque et si ce n'est pire et
pour tous les jeunes et en particulier
les jeunes de banlieue et disons les
choses
les jeunes qui ont une peau moins clair
que d'autres pour cela il ya un risque
et c'est connu et le savent
tout le monde le sait le défenseur des
droits a sorti un rapport je croyais
roux avant-hier dans lequel il met en
cause le fait que il pointe du doigt le
fait il ya des pratiques de
discrimination dans la police dans les
contrôles est évidemment dans les
violences qui sont exercées sur sur des
personnes c'est une réalité
et le problème c'est que et c'est là
qu'on peut s'inquiéter d'une fille née
du discours de du
du ministre de l'intérieur c'est que il
fait des grandes phrases sur le fait
qu'aucun aucun acte ne sera ne sera tous
les actes de racisme qui existeraient
serait sur la sanctionner mais sauf
qu'en même temps il tient un discours
qui consiste à dire que enfin
globalement il n'y a rien et circulez ya
rien à voir
je crois que c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
résoudre le problème il s'agit pas de
stigmatiser l'ensemble des policiers
français
il s'agit de regarder de manière lucide
le comportement de la police à l'égard
en particulier d'une certaine frange de
la population qui est parmi ceux là le
sondage on ne serait même pas à 1/3 2/3
aux trois tiers de la population ou ou
trois quarts de la population qui
considérait 100 % des jeunes dans ces
quartiers là savent qu'ils peuvent faire
l'objet de contrôles systématiques
répéter parfois plusieurs fois dans la
même journée
il ya un vrai problème ou bien on le
regarde en face tel qu'il est ou bien on
se contente de deux grandes phrases mais
en mettant la poussière sous le tapis
merci guillaume à martin d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france